المخ هو سيد الجسد والروح من حيث اتصاله
بكافه اجهزه الجسم عبر الجهاز العصبي لذلك
فان اي اصابه يتعرض لها المخ تؤدي الى ضرر
في بقيه الاعضاء يشكل حجم المخ حوالي
اثنين في المئه فقط من الوزن الاجمالي
لجسم الانسان كله ورغم ذلك يحصل على اكثر
من 15% من غذاء الانسان عن طريق الدوره
الدمويه ويعتبر المخ عضله من عضلات الجسم
وتبدا في التكون منذ بدايات تكون الجنين
في رحم الام فذكرت دوريه جانا لعلوم
الاعصاب ان مخها الذكور ينمو بسرعه اكبر
مقارنه بالاناث الرضع وللمخ مهام كثيره
ومتعدده منها التخيل والتمييز والتتابع
واللغه والحساب والمنطق والاستنتاج وغيرها
للحفاظ على لياقه هذه العضلات يجب ان
نتعامل معها كباقي عضلات الجسم من خلال
التمارين كي لا تصاب بالضمور وتزداد هذه
العضلات نشاطا بالعمل وتتعطل بالكسل ومع
العمل يكون الدماغ قادرا على القيام
بعمليات حسابيه معقده وفي وقت قياسي حيث
يحتوي هذا العضو على ملايين الخلايا التي
تقوم بتخزين بلايين المعلومات
[موسيقى]